j'ouvre tout de suite le second débat de
de sens public consacré au rapport remis
la semaine dernière par la civise la
commission indépendante sur l'inceste et
les violences sexuelles faites aux
enfants il contient 750 pages 30000
témoignages de victimes 83 % de femmes
parmi ces témoignages et 82
recommandations quelles sont ces
recommandations la réponse de l'État
est-elle à la hauteur de ce que l'on
peut appeler un crime de masse avec
160000 enfants victimes chaque année de
violence sexuelle avant d'en débattre je
vous propose un témoignage le témoignage
d'Arnaud galet il est anthropologue
aujourd'hui il vient de publier un livre
choc sur ce qu'il a subi dans son
enfance Flora sauvage j'ai été violé
entre l'âge de 8 ans et 11 ans par un
prêtre pédocriminel c'était lié d'amitié
avec mon père et en fait à chaque fois
qu'il venait en France mon père allait
le chercher à l'aéroport et il venait
dormir chez nous et et et à chaque fois
d'ailleurs il le faisait DMIR dans ma
chambre euh alors que ça j'ai jamais
compris pourquoi il y avait une chambre
d'ami euh dans laquelle il aurait pu
dormir sauf qu'elle était pas rangée et
ceter c'est toujours le prétexte qui m'a
été donné et donc il dormait dans ma
chambre non personnellement c'était un
moment où je faisais pipi au lit en fait
à l'époque donc ben à chaque fois qu'il
venait dormir dans ma chambre il me
faisait venir au bout d'un moment dans
son lit me demandait donc de me
déshabiller donc ce que je faisais
j'étais complètement souillé et de là en
fait il commençait par bah on va dire ce
qu'on appellerait plutôt à mon sens une
forme de découverte de mon corps j'étais
complètement tétanisé et j'ai compris
après que j'étais dans un état de
dissociation complet quoi je veux dire c
j'étais complètement en état de choc euh
et de là en fait il faisait un peu ce
qu'il voulait de moi et mais j'avais
vraiment l'impression euh par ailleurs
d'avoir été acteur là-dedans de me dire
bah tiens c'est peut-être moi qui l'ai
voulu j'ai rien dit et cetera il y a un
truc qui est très confus tout simplement
parce qu'on sait pas ce que c'est quand
on est enfant et bah de de de subir une
agression sexuelle puceque moi
initialement ça passé quand même par
desah la masturbation des choses comme
ça et après bah pire d'être sodomisé et
cetera comme ça m'est arrivé non ce que
vousz sous l'emprise de son agresseur
Arnaud ne parvient pas à révéler les
viols qu'il subit jusqu'à ce qu'il brise
le silence à l'âge de 19 ans grâce à un
reportage sur France 3 je dis c'est ce
qui m'est arrivé et là j'explique à mes
parents qui étaient tous les deux devant
la télé bah voilà ce que Rémy lorando
qui était donc le nom du prêtre qui
était prêtre missionnaire et qui était
également donc un grand oncle m'a fait
mais m'a fait sans revenir justement sur
la stratégie puisque j'ai fait comme
beaucoup d'enfants ce qu'on appelle une
amnésie traumatique partielle donc je me
souvenais pas de l'ensemble je me
souvenais juste de de j'avais juste
certains flash j'ai parlé tardivement
parce que les conditions n'étaient pas
réunies ou parce que les personnes ne
voulaient pas voir moi je le dis hein
d'une certaine manière la société est
consentante à ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui
elle ne elle souhaite ne pas voir voilà
on peut le dire autrement ou faire
d'autres parallèles si on regarde
l'histoire de Vanessa springera par
exemple c'est éclairant c'estàd tout le
monde était au courant et personne ne
faisait rien alors que à l'époque tutait
pas autorisé quoi en réalité donc
désormais Arnaud galet se bat au
quotidien pour que la parole des enfants
soit entendue et réclame un plan Marchal
de la protection de l'enfance récemment
160000 enfants sont victimes de violence
sexuelle chaque année en France voilà je
me permettez juste je trouve ça très
bien de le faire dans les justement à
quoi pourrait ressembler à un plan
Marchal de lutte contre les violences
sexuelles faites aux enfants en débat
avec Édouard Duran bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes coprésident de de la
civice de la commission indépendante sur
l'incesse et les violences sexuelles
faites aux enfants vous êtes juges des
enfants également Dominique Verrien
bonsoir bonsoir sénatrice Union
centriste de de Lyonne présidente de la
délégation au droits des femmes au Sénat
et à l'égalité des chances entre les les
hommes et les femmes on attend Muriel
Salmona psychiatre présidente de
l'association mémoire traumatique et
membre permanent de la CIVIS elle va
arriver dans dans un instant Émilie
zapalski évidemment est resté à mes
côtés je vais je vais commencer je vais
rappeler ce ce constat on a on a entendu
les les chiffres dans dans notre sujet
d'ouverture qui est quand même effrayant
il y a beaucoup de de chiffres et de
constats qui sont glaçants 160000
enfants victimes chaque année de
violence sexuelle un enfant toutes les 3
minutes et puis si on va chercher un
autre chiffre une personne sur 10 a été
victime de violence sexuelle dans son
enfance ça représente aujourd'hui près
de
5500000 adultes Arnaud galet qu'on vient
d'entendre il il parle dans le reportage
de Flora de massacre de masse est-ce que
c'est aussi le constat que vous avez
fait après 3 ans de travail à la civise
oui il faut bien prendre en
compte que il s'agit d'une réalité
extrêmement massive vous avez dit ce
chiffre un enfant toutes les 3 minutes
combien de temps allons-nous être réunis
ce soir pour parler pendant ce temps
combien d'enfants seront victimes de
viol ou d'agression sexuelle toujours
dans des lieux où les enfants sont
censés vivre en confiance et en sécurité
c'est eux le plus souvent exactement et
l'ampleur c'est aussi la gravité et ce
que ces 30000 témoignages d'adulte nous
montre c'est que l'impact pendant
l'enfance est est extrême de de
bouleversement du monde il faut il faut
s'imaginer un petit garçon une petite
fille des adolescents parfois des
nourrissons la vie s'arrête mais ça
continue pendant toute la vie d'adulte
et la souffrance est telle que parfois
certaines personnes arrête la vie pour
arrêter la souffrance c'est ça dont nous
allons parler et c'est pour ça
qu'effectivement moi j'ai repris aussi
ce terme de de massacre de masse
Dominique Verrien comment on peut c'est
vraiment un nous nous société
française tolérer ces violences à nos
portes chez nos voisins parfois dans nos
familles c'est j'ai pas forcément la
réponse hein mais comment depuis des
décennies on peut tolérer ça je crois
que quand on ouvre les yeux c'est
intolérable h mais trop de personnes ne
les ouvrent pas et donc voilà pourquoi
ça peut continuer à se faire si on le
vit pas soi-même si on le côtoit pas si
on n'a pas accès comme la civise l'a eu
à tous ces témoin tmoignage ça paraît
peu croyable et puis on a cette
présomption d'innocence qui se justifie
mais qui il est vrai sert
systématiquement la personne qui est
l'auteur il y a le fait que on a du mal
à croire l'enfant parce que c'est une
parole d'enfant il y a le fait qu'on n
pas formé à ce que c'est que le
psychotraumatisme à on n'est pas formé à
ce que c'est que sur d'autres sujets moi
je travaille sur le contrôle veritif sur
les violences intrafamiliales mais de
toute façon les enfantsi sont
systématiquement victimes et et si les
services sociaux si les forces de
sécurité intérieure si les magistrats si
toutes les personnes qui sont en contact
avec les enfants ne connaissent pas ces
notions là et bien effectivement on va
dire que c'est parole contre parole et
avec une parole d'enfant qu'on ne croira
pas ouais on a titrer ce débat euh
est-ce vraiment la fin du dénis euh
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça est-ce
que vous est-ce que votre rapport marque
la fin du déni d'une certaine façon je
l'espère et je veux le croire c'est une
décision qui est une décision collective
c'est-à-dire de de de chaque citoyen
personnellement et du groupe humain que
nous formons puis c'est une décision de
politique publique il ne faut pas faire
porter tout ça sur les épaules de
l'enseignante du médecin de la juge des
parents du policier ou du gendarme du
gendarm c'est une politique publique qui
décidons-nous de éger les agresseurs
ou les enfants vous pour vous c'est
cette alternative là jusqu'à présent on
a protégé les agresseurs mais le dénis
c'est ça ouais et et le l'inceste les
violences sexuelles faites aux enfants
c'est le dénis le plus constant de de
l'histoire humaine c'est c'est c'est un
fait je suis pas anthropologue comme
Arna galet mais je pense qu'on peut dire
que c'est un fait anthropologique
constant et et ce dénis et bien ce
infiltre le le fonctionnement social de
de la justice des soins aussi bien on va
en parler avec Muriel Salmona dans un
instant comment se fait-il qu'au nom de
principe on attendre plusieurs mois
plusieurs années pour décider de
protéger un enfant comment se fait-il
que dans le doute on prenne le risque
d'envoyer un enfant chez son
violeur comment répondre à cette
question c'est un système d'impunité le
déni c'est ça h
miliepp oui moi il me semble que c'est
une question qui me fait penser à
l'anthropologie c'est vraiment la
constitution des sociétés parce qu'on a
l'impression que dans ce dénis c'est
impossible de voir je sais pas son mari
son son enfant si c'est dans le cas d'un
inceste de de frères et de sœurs devenir
ces monstres là c'est inimaginable pour
une société pour une famille il me
semble de voir ces monstre là et donc
c'est pas acceptable de le dire de
l'exprimer je pense que c'est là cet
ordre du dénis et c'est comme si la
société c'était fabriqué comme ça qu'on
on se protège quelque part parce qu'on
veut pas voir cette horreur là donc on
le fait pas sortir et moi je suis
d'accord avec vous ça veut pas reposer
ne serait-ce que sur les épaules d'un
enfant qui plus tard comme on le voit
avec le témoignage d'Arnaud galet ou
quoi qui même moi j'en connais hein qui
a 50 ans disent bah oui j'ai subi ça je
pouvais pas le dire avant je me rendais
même pas compte tellement c'était
dur de voir ces gens-là qui étaient des
proches qui étaient de la famille parce
que souvent c'est dans la famille hein
c'est ce que vous dites dans votre
rapport euh c'est inacceptable c'est une
espèce de chape de béton qu'on a
constitué les familles se sont
constituées comme ça et et c'est bien si
on commence à sortir de ça c'est comme
si on on faisait une étape
anthropologique intéressante dans les
familles pour dire et ben oui ça peut
exister ça va détruire forcément des
familles des gens mais il faut
absolument sortir ça et que ça repose
pas sur les enfants qui soient dans les
médias ou qui trouvent un autre une
autre façon d'être protégé quelque part
allez-y VI intervenir oui pour aller au
bout de la question que vous posez et
vous apportez des éléments de réponse
très précieux madame il y a
l'irreprésentable oui
la
scène de viol d'un enfant c'est de
l'ordre de l'irreprésentable je suis
d'accord il y a aussi la tolérance du
fait bien sûr c'est-à-dire la
représentation et
l'acceptation ce qui est aussi une
réalité et dans les 30000 témoignages
que nous avons reçu nous voyons ça nous
voyons
que mais sur des chaînes de télé comme
celle-ci il y a pas si longtemps on
pouvait le dire librement qu'on avait
ces actesl sur les enfants c'est
pourquoi je dis qui vous oh mais c'était
une autre époque alors on dit c'est une
autre époque mais qu'est-ce qui va
qu'est-ce qui va nous garantir qu'on ne
reviendra pas à cette époque-elà et bien
moi je crois que
c'est la prise de conscience que ces
êtres humains existent et que là ils se
sont levés et ont pris la parole ça
c'est un fait nouveau et puis dans le
silence en fait il y a aussi le fait que
euh les membres veulent maintenir cette
famille soudée et donc celui qu'on va
rejeter c'est celui qui
parlera et donc il a intérêt s'il veut
rester dans une cellule parce que la
cellule familiale c'est celle aussi à
laquelle on va s'identifier et qui est
censé nous nous protéger et donc être
exclu du clan familial c'est se
retrouver totalement seul dans la
société donc ça va courage pour faire
exploser ça va provoquer le silence moi
je me souviens quand j'étais étudiante
j'avais une une jeune fille qui avait
dénoncé euh les actes de de viol de son
père pour éviter que ça arrive à sa
petite sœur h euh ses frères sont venus
l'attendre à la sortie de l'école pour
lui casser la figure parce que elle
avait elle détruisait leur famille c'est
jamais elle était la victime elle était
celle qui détruisait la famille ou je
vous l'ai dit en en préambule en
démarrant ce ce débat il y a beaucoup de
de statistiques de chiffres qui sont
dans votre dans le rapport de la civise
qui sont vraiment glaçants notamment ben
justement sur l'inceste le fait que ça
se passe dans la famille 81 % des viol
vience sexuelle se déroule dans le cadre
familial c'était le cas d'hélen car je
vous propose son témoignage elle est
aujourd'hui sophrologue dans sa jeunesse
de 6 à 14 ans elle a été manipulée et
violée par son frère et ses cousins j'ai
encore dans ma tête les les bruits et
les rires des adultes qui étaient en bas
et et nous on était en haut et et en
fait on était chacun sur un matelas et
là j'ai senti le plus âgé de mes cousins
qui est arrivé derrière moi et et en
fait j'ai plus bougé à partir de ce
moment-là euh et et j'ai senti en fait
son sexe qui durcissait derrière moi euh
et à partir de ce moment-là il a
commencé à me mettre la main sur la
bouche puisque moi je me rendais bien
compte qu'il y avait quelque chose qui
allait pas mais à ce
moment-là il me glissait dans l'oreille
que il fallait rien que je dise que si
jamais je disais quelque chose à
quelqu'un il allait faire du mal aux
personnes que j'aimais hlen car qu'elle
a trouvé malgré tout le courage de
dénoncer son frère et ses cousins voici
ce que son père lui a répondu la
première fois que j'ai j'ai demandé à
mon père de venir et que je lui expliqué
ce qui s'est passé mon père a minimisé
c'était comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'est c'est mais moi je jouis à
touche pipi avec mes sœurs et on en a
pas fait toute une histoire quoi tout le
monde fait ça c'est normal les enfants
ils se
découvrent sauf que quand un frère il
met des préservatifs pour pas vous
mettre enceinte on est sur un autre
niveau en fait on est plus sur la
découverte des corps euh on va commencer
à à avancer sur les les préconisations
du du du rapport Édouard Duran qu'est-ce
que vous proposez justement pour sortir
de ce de ce silence comment aider les
victimes à trouver une oreille qui va
qui va qui va être attentive dire je
vous crois et pas oh là là tout le monde
a fait ça eu c'est c'est le plus
important h parce que c'est comme ça que
on enclenche la chaîne de la protection
personne ne peut protéger tout seul il
faut être une chaîne c'est pour ça que
c'est une politique publique c'est c'est
une fonctionnement sociale ce que nous
avons montré dans notre rapport c'est
qu'il y a trois grands types de réponses
quand un enfant révèle des violences je
te crois je te protège le soutien social
positif je te crois mais rien le silence
un second anéantissement soutien social
négatif et tu
mens tu détruis la famille l'absence de
soutien social et bien seul 8 % des
enfants reçoivent un soutien social
positif parce qu'il y a pas assez de
structure ce n'est pas une question de
moyen c'est une question de volonté
c'est une question d'acceptation de la
réalité qu'est-ce que c'est le dénis
c'est ça n'existe pas je ne veux pas que
ça soit vrai ça n'est pas grave ça ne me
regarde pas il n'y a rien à faire c'est
ça le déni et à chaque fois vous allez
voir ce type de réponse
or tout le monde fait ça ce que cette
femme a dit très justement la réponse de
son père c'est normal tout le monde fait
c'est ça oui les agresseurs disent ça
ils disent aussi si tu parles je te tue
si tu parles tu vas détruire la famille
tu vas faire du mal si tu parles tu vas
aller au commissariat et on ne te croira
pas ce qui se passe malheureusement et
bien autant de raisons qui font que
l'enfant victime se demande s'il va être
cru et tous les enfants victimes le
disent ce qui m'a empêché de parler
c'est la peur de ne pas être cru c'est
pourquoi il ne faut pas attendre que les
enfants parlent il faut aller leur poser
la question c'est notre première
préconisation le repérage par le
questionnement systématique on dit dans
une place fait où il se fait où ce
questionnement à l'école partout vous
allez chez le médecin votre médecin doit
vous demander mais si il y a des
antécédents cardiovasculaires dans votre
famille mais il doit également vous
demander si vous avez été victime de
violence dans votre enfance parce que
c'est un déterminant majeur de la santé
à l'âge adulte ça doit se faire à
l'école ça doit se faire chez
l'éducateur ça doit se faire chez la
psychologue quand j'étais juge des
enfants je posais la question des
violences à tous les enfants il y a des
enfants mais oui et même aux enfants
délinquantsou enfants qui me disent
parfois qu'on leur fait des choses
qu'ils n'aiment pas oui est-ce que toi
il y a des choses qu'on te fait et que
tu n'aimes pas parce que alors l'enfant
se dira je peux lui dire elle va me
croire il va me protéger il sera capable
dans sa tête de mettre les imag des mots
que je vais dire donc ce ce tabou de la
question il faut vraiment le retourner
c'estàd que tout le monde ose poser la
question aux enfants ou même aux adultes
est-ce que ça vous est arrivé voilà
j'entends j'entends vraiment cet
argument qui est essentiel c'est
d'autant plus important Dominique
verrier que alors là on parla juste à
titre de de l'inceste mais vous aviez
vous étiez corrapportrice d'un d'un
travail au au Sénat rapport sur ce sur
le thème en 2019 de des violences dans
les institutions d'accueil des enfants
alors là on est on est presque dans le
pire du pire c'estàdire que ce sont des
lieux où les enfants sont supposés être
protégés accueillis et évidemment ils y
subissent enfin évidemment
malheureusement ils subissent aussi des
violences sexuelles c'est un peu est-ce
que ça passe un peu sous les sous les
radars d'une certaine façon ça al on va
pas si on parle de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance c'est sûr que là on a un vrai
sujet euh et parce que non seulement les
enfants qui viennent là sont des enfants
qui ont besoin d'être protégés parfois
parce qu'ils ont été justement victime
de violence sexuelle mais on sait aussi
que parmi les victimes un certain nombre
vont reproduire et il se trouve que les
éducateurs qui accueillent ses enfants
ne savent pas si les enfants qu'ils ont
sont des victimes et donc
potentiellement ils peuvent mettre dans
la même chambre un auteur et une victime
par mécnaissances par mesconnaissances
parce que parce qu'on ne pose pas la
question que vous que vous posez à
l'instant alors en règle générale on le
sait les magistrats le savent mais alors
il y a le secret on ne veut pas dire il
y a vraiment du secret aussi on ne veut
pas dire et probablement lié à un tabou
parce que si l'enfant était diabétique
on saurait le dire quand même que on
doit pas lui donner à manger n'importe
quoi pourquoi parce que il est victime
de violence sexuelle on le dirait pas
pour dire celui-là il faut le protéger
plus que d'autres effectivement je je
j'entends votre votre argument voulez
intervenir moi j'ai une question ça va
être ma casquette féministe à nouveau
j'ai une question parce que on voit dans
le profil il y a quand même une majorité
large
d'hommes plus que large c'est
7% c'est quasiment
voilà les agresseurs sont des hommes
quoi il faut dire les choses clairement
on peut dire oui évidment est-ce qu'il y
a une question peut-être justement de
société ou op logique qui explique voilà
il y a une espèce de je sais pas comment
on peut dire de plein pouvoir quoi de je
peux faire ça comme on a le cas et on
est en train de travailler dessus la
société heureusement travaille dessus
sur les violences faites aux femmes et
tout ce qui se passe il y a aussi un
tabou hein qui se lève là-dessus est-ce
qu'il y a quelque chose de l'ordre de
bah quand je suis homme dans ma famille
pour les femmes je généralise pas mais
là quand même 97 % une expression
expression du patriarcat quoi je suis
propriétaire de l'intégralité de la
famille et donc je peux euh quand mêmeou
c'est une façon de posséder c'est le
terme en plus je je vous propose de
répondre à la question et on accueille
Muriel Salmona qui peut rentrer sur sur
ce plateau en attendant bien bienvenue
installez-vous je vous présente dans un
instant je laisse rochement avec les
violences conjugales est tout à fait
juste les mécanismes sont les mêmes la
stratégie de l'agresseur est la même et
l'impact psychotraumatique est la même
et les fondements sont les mêmes la
violence même quand elle passe par le
sexe n'est jamais qu'un instrument du
pouvoir violence sexuelle n'est pas de
la sexualité c'est un instrument de
domination d'écrasement ça veut toujours
dire tu m'appartiens tu es ma chose que
qu'il s'agisse du père ou du de d'un
professeur ou de ou de d'un prêtre peu
importe c'est toujours un acte de
domination et oui la quasi-ttalité des
agresseurs sont de sexes masculin la
quasittalité des victimes de sexe
féminin mais quand les victimes sont des
enfants la proportion de garçon est plus
importante qu'à l'âge adulte h Muriel
Salmona merci de de nous rejoindre vous
êtes psychiatre présidente de
l'association mémoire traumatique et
victimologie membre permanente de la
cise la commission indépendante sur
l'inceste et les violences sexuelles
faites aux enfants ben voilà on est en
plein débat sur le le le le finalement
l'instrument d'un pouvoir d'un pouvoir
masculin est-ce qu'il faut commencer par
éduquer les petits garçons tiens pour
pour renverser la la table pour sortir
de ce démis oui al il y a il y a
vraiment tout un tout un travail très
important autour de
l'égalité euh autour du respect d'autrui
du respect du concentement d'autrui des
toute cette éducation et puis il y a
aussi un travail important puisqu'on le
sait euh beaucoup de ces euh de ces
petits garçons qui deviendront des
agresseurs souvent même déjà mineurs ont
été exposé à des violences sexuelles
soit en tant que victime soit en tant
que témoin et déjà si on aussi on les
dép en tant que victime on éviterait la
mise en place de tout un parcours
ensuite d'AG par d'un d'un continuum de
violence a un continuum de violence il y
a une très grande étude de l'ONU qui a
montré que avoir subi des violences
sexuelles et physiques dans l'enfance
pour une femme pour un pour une fille ça
a multiplié par 16 le risque de subir
des violences conjugales et sexuelles à
l'âge adulte et par 14 pour les garçons
de commettre des violences sexistes des
violences conjugales et des violences
sexuelles à l'âge adulte donc on
pourrait tout arrêter si on repérait le
plus tôt possible et si on et on
protégeit ses enfants et si on donnait
des soins parce que les soins évitent
justement la la reproduction de violence
que ce soit en terme de violence qu'on
va à nouveau subir ou commettre c'est
des troubles psychotraumatiques qui sont
à l'œuvre dans tous ces systèmes édard
durant nous parlait tout à l'heure de
l'importance de de la détection en fait
et effectivement plus on détecte t mieux
c'est donc l'importance de poser doser
poser les question question tabou est-ce
qu'il y a aussi Monal Salmona des
comportements que qu'on peut nous
collectivement voyez détecter je des des
comportements autodestructeurs ou ou
d'autres qui n permettent de dire
attention il y a peut-être là un petit
garçon une petite fille qui est victime
de violence tout à fait il y a il y a il
y a énormément de de symptômes qui sont
ce qu'on appelle pathogneumoni
pathognumoniqu qui sont des preuves qui
s'est passé quelque chose de
traumatique que c'est mais toujours il
faut toujours quand même poser
systématiquement la question parce qu'il
y a toujours des enfants qui sont
tellement traumatisés qui vont être dans
un état de dissociation de déconnexion
émotionnelle qui vont passer qui vont
être invisibilisés qu'on veut pas avoir
mais sinon tout changement de
comportement brutal euh tout
comportement de toute toute situation de
souffrance mentale toute situation de
comportement sexuel inapproprié de
conduite à risque de d'agressivité euh
de de mise en danger euh et
d'automutilation mais aussi toutes les
toutes les situations de phobie de de de
en fait de troubl anxieux tout ça et de
trouble alimentaire aussi de trouble du
sommeil tous ces comportementsl vont
être vont vont vont devoir être des
alertes et tout aussi problème à
l'école problème vraiment d'agressivité
d'opposition ou de de ce qu'on appelle
des angoisses de séparation ou de
trouble régressifs aussi des enfants qui
se remettent à faire pipi au lit avoir
de l'encomprisie tout ça doit interroger
il y a un signe de souffrance il y a un
signe de malaise on doit absolument
rechercher ce qui s'est passé qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pour que tu te
sentes si mal et qu'est-ce qui est-ce
qu'il y a quelqu'un qui t'a fait du mal
ouis ce sont ça fait partie des des
hasards de l'actualité mais aujourd'hui
on a appris que triste tigre qui est le
livre de neige co récide de l'incesseste
qu'elle a subi a obtenu le le goncours
des des lycéens voilà c'est
h ce qui est un très bon prix et je
relis cette information euh au succès du
film qui est adapté du roman de Vanessa
springora le consentement succès qui
s'est construit comment grâce à une
sorte de bouche à oreille des
adolescents sur TikTok euh qui ont
commencé à parler de ce film et ce film
qui avait pas très bien marché la
première semaine est en train de très
bien marcher est-ce que Édouard Durand
il y a là un message qu'une génération
est en train de nous
envoyer vous qui êtes au pouvoir
bougez-vous vous voyez ce que je veux
dire
il il est certain que la
littérature
a une
capacité inégalée qui lui est propre de
faire voir le réel Christine Ango disait
de de son œuvre je veux que les mots
soient visibles et c'est fondamental
pour répondre à ce que nous évoquions au
début de l'émission comment se
représenter ce que on ne veut pas voir
ce qu'on veut éloigner de soi euh n sino
par triste tigre et toute cette
réflexion sur la littérature sur les
violences sexuelles nous nous nous
emporte vraiment dans une prise de
conscience que je que je trouve
magnifique je dois dire que je suis
beaucoup plus réservé
sur le le ce qui a été fait du livre de
Vanessa springorain moi j'ai vu ce film
ouis je je n'ai pas accepté d'être mis
en position de spectateur de viol
pédocriminel je vous dis les choses
comme je les pense et
et malgré le consentement qu'on prête à
cette écrivaine à
nouveau je je reste beaucoup plus
réservé vous voyez des manières de de
faire penser la violence qui ne sont pas
sidérantes ni séductrices alors moi
j'avoue je n'ai pas vu le film donc je
peux pas donner d'avis sur le film ce
qui ce que je trouvais intéressant
c'était le le mouvement on va dire parmi
une partie la jeunesse française il il y
a un autre chiffre je reviens au au
rapport que vous avez publié qui est lui
aussi effrayant pour moi c'est peut-être
le plus accablant seul 3 % des viols et
des agressions sexuelles commis chaque
année sur des enfants font l'objet d'une
condamnation des agresseurs Dominique
Verrien là aussi comment est-ce que
c'est pas le constat d'une faillite
collective ce chire c'est pas seulement
la justice qui est en cause 3% seulement
justice mais quand je vous parlais de
formation je vais vous donner un exemple
et Murielle Salmona est là mais je vais
le dire devant elle euh elle a été
invitée chez à l'association France
victime de Lyonne il y a quelques années
notre procureur était dans la salle et
en entendant Muriel Salmona a dit mais
il faut que tout le monde sache parce
que tant qu'on ne sait pas ce que c'est
que le
psychotraumatisme euh on ne sait pas
comprendre ce qu'est une victime et du
coup on ne sait pas l'entendre h et donc
euh du coup la procureur a organisé une
grande réunion où muriel est est venue
et ça a tout changé dans Lyonne alors on
n'est pas non plus euh les rois du monde
et mais mais la formation on est très
bon mais mais la formation objectivement
euh de toutes les forces de sécurité des
magistrats euh tout le monde s'y est mis
parce que tout le monde a compris que là
il y avait quelque chose et des services
sociaux qui étaient tous présents tout
le monde a compris qu'on passait à côté
de quelque chose et que du coup pas
passant à côté on ne protégeit pas ce
qu'on devait protéger que ce soit des
femmes ou des enfants et réellement tant
qu'on n pas su ça et moi le fait de voir
le changement on a un avant après son
passage mais vraiment très clair dans le
département et tant qu'on a pas vécu ça
et donc tant qu'on a pas une formation
et toutes les personnes qui suivent des
formations me disent j'ai changé ma
pratique et tant qu'on n' pas toutes les
personnes qui sont formées et qui ne
changent pas leur pratique et donc qui
ne savent pas reconnaître et qui
continuent à dire ses paroles contre
paroles alors que c'est derrière une
porte fermée donc il faut bien
reconnaître les signaux pour voir qu'il
y a effectivement une victime et s'il y
a une victime et bien il y a bien un
auteur et objectivement l'auteur est
assez facile à trouver ouais on va
parler d'une des préconisations de de de
votre rapport qui concerne
l'imprescriptibilité des violences
sexuelles sur les enfants je propose à
audre vuetaz de nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau on va on va déjà rebonsçoir a
faire un peu de pédagogie
imprescriptibilité on parle de quoi
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire tout
simplement qu'il faut changer la loi qui
date de 2018 car actuellement les
victimes de violence sexuelle pendant
leur enfance peuvent déposer plainte
jusqu'à l'âge de 48 ans ça veut dire 30
ans après avoir atteint leur majorité
au-delà les faits sont considérés comme
prescrits aucune poursuite judiciaire
n'est donc plus possible sauf que ces
violentes peuvent être si traumatisantes
et je parle sous votre contrôle Muriel
salbona que le cerveau peut oublier ce
qui est arrivé c'est arrivé justement à
miyekyyama les souvenirs lui sont
remontés 32 ans plus tard trop tard pour
que sa plainte soit acceptée l'affaire a
été classée sans suite écoutez son
témoignage c'était au micro de Flor
sauvage on a le sentiment qu'on est
victime une seconde fois de ces viols en
fait donc c'est comme si ces crimes
enfin c'est comme si c'est cri on a
besoin d'une réponse enfin moi j'avais
besoin d'une réponse judiciaire à ces
crimes et et le terme de prescription
c'était presque insupportable en fait
c'est enfin l'idée je pouvais la
comprendre intellectuellement le droit à
l'oublie mais c'était exactement
l'inverse de ce que je vivais dans mes
émotions physiquement psychologiquement
intellectuellement c'est l'une des
raisons pour laquelle la CIVIS demande
l'imprescriptibilité des violence
sexuelle contre les enfants c'est-à-dire
qu'il n'y ait plus d'âge limite pour
porter plainte le sujet est d'ailleurs
régulièrement poussé par des
associations elle revient au le sujet
revient au Parlement mais il se heurte
aux arguments des défenseurs de la
prescription qui estiment qu'au bout
d'un certain temps la solidité des
preuves et les témoignages est sujette à
caution ce qui peut conduire à des
classements sans suite et donc à une
double peine pour les victimes je
continue la liste des arguments les
auteurs de violence ne sont plus les
mêmes après plusieurs décennies enfin
certains défenseurs de la prescription
mentionnent fait aussi le fait
qu'actuellement il n'y a que les crimes
contre l'humanité qui sont
imprescriptibles et ils veulent que cela
reste ainsi je vous propose d'écouter le
garde des saut à ce sujet pourquoi pas
l'imprescriptibilité des meurtres des
assassinats où il y a aussi des victimes
de vraies victimes bien sûr comme dans
toutes ces
infractions absolument atroce il y a
aussi la question du dépérissement de la
preuve bien évidemment certain nombre de
un certain nombre de très haut
magistrats de ce pays se sont exprimés
sur cette question sont défavorables à
l'imprescriptibilité il y a aussi l'idée
même de ce qu'est la prescription il a
fallu des millénaires pour que notre
société civilisée envisage ce qui'est la
prescription elle a aussi un certain
nombre d'avantages sociaux sociétaux
qu'on ne peut pas sous le coup de
l'émotion balayer d'un revers de manche
et puis je termine par un dernier
argument il a été émis par la sénatrice
centriste anque billon c'est le fait que
la prescription sert dans certains cas
de déclencheur une date limite peut
pousser les victimes à porter plines
merci beaucoup audreet pour toutes ces
informations Muriel Salmona je reviens
vers vous parce que vous faites partie
des des psychiatres qui ont contribué on
va dire à définir la notion de d'amnésie
traumatique est-ce que cette cette
notion justifie pour vous évidemment
l'imprescriptibilité alors c'est oui
parce que effectivement là c'est pas
c'est la victime et et dans l'incapacité
de pouvoir faire valoir ses droits et de
de porter peintte et que ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas sa faute c'est le trauma qui
génère un mécanisme de sauvegarde au
niveau du cerveau qui va déconnecter les
les circuits émotionnels les circuits de
la mémoire et tant que la victime en
fait est en situation de danger tant
qu'elle est pas protégée tant qu'elle
est pas soignée tant tant qu'elle est
exposée souvent aux agresseur ou système
agresseur elle reste dissociée et c'est
souvent très longtemps il faut être
souvent très longtemps pour qu'elle soit
enfin protégée particulièrement dans les
situations d'inceste ou c'est même
jusqu'à 50 % des victimes qui présentent
des des périodes d'amnésie traumatique
et l'argument consiste à dire la
prescription ça peut être un déclencheur
ce que nous
disaitant je pense que on peut pas poser
un argument par rapport à certaines
personnes alors que l'immense majorité
des autres sont en incapacité de pouvoir
porter plainte et que déclencheur ou pas
ça va pas changer grand-chose leur
incapacité elle est là et c'est ne pas
penser au plus vulnérable à toutes les
personnes parce que faut rappeler aussi
que plus les personnes sont plus les les
les victimes enfants sont vulnérables
plus ils subissent de violence
particulièrement les enfants en
situation de handicap et qui vont que
leur cerveau est encore plus vulnérable
il va y avoir encore plus de difficultés
à porter plainte ouai euh hardant on a
eu quelques argument mais vous vous
préconisez la fin de
l'imprescriptibilité euh pourquoi
qu'est-ce que vous répondez tiens par
exemple à euh au Garde des saut qui qui
s'exprimait sur ce sujet il y a il y a 2
ans premièrement que euh il ne s'agit
pas d'une préconisation qui a été
formulée sous l'emprise de l'émotion HM
euh les personnes qui sont euh attentive
à ce que vivent les victimes ne sont pas
débordés par l'émotion la raison est de
tous les côtés premier élément c'est un
argument d'autorité et je ne vois pas
qui serait légitime à s'attribuer euh
l'autorité de la raison deuxièmement
nous y avons beaucoup réfléchi nous
avons mis 3 ans en auditionnant des
historiens des philosophes des des des
psychiatres et pédopsychiatres des
juristes évidemment et nous avons
examiné les fondements de la
prescription une civilisation oui c'est
vrai h construit des régimes de droit
qu'est-ce qu'on voit premier élément
fondement de des règles de prescription
il y a la carence du
plignant vous auriez dû parler quand il
était temps de
parler alors qu'il y a l'amnésie
traumatique alors que vous êtes sous
l'emprise d'un système institutionnel
familial qui vous empêche de parler
alors que la société
dénit ce que vous êtes en train de dire
il y a un autre argument qui est le fait
que le coupable pendant toute la durée
où les faits ne sont pas prescrits
aurait vécu dans l'inquiétude et aurait
subi une forme de peine qui l'aurait
changé mais nous avons mais c'est au
fondement de la prescription bien sûr et
nous nous avons des agresseurs des
témoignages où des personnes nous disent
mais moi j'ai subi 1000 viols dans mon
enfance il y a des il y a des agresseurs
qui font jusqu'à 150 plus même de
victimes on dit la paix
sociale la paix de qui la paix de qui
c'est pour arranger qui vous voyez ce
qui garantit la PAI sociale c'est que la
loi soit remise à sa place dernier point
pardon d'être mais je voudrais quand
même le dire c'est que évidemment nous
nous nous avons avec beaucoup de de
d'humilité permettez-moi de le dire
aborder cette question y compris ce la
question de notre histoire nous sommes
des des enfants de la 2uxè partie du 20e
siècle et et ce n'est ni sous le coup de
l'émotion ou de la déraison que nous
avons avancé vers cette préconisation
la prescription n'est pas le critère
social de la mesure de la gravité d'un
crime ce n'est pas le critère Dominique
Verrien votre avis sur sur cette ce
thème là la l'imprescriptibilité il y a
un autre argument qui est la difficulté
de réunir des lendemain Mme quand c'est
le lendemain des a déjà pas de preu
domien votre avis alors c'est vrai que
il y a le le sujet des preuve je pense
que ce qu'il faut alors moi jusqu'à
présent peut-être que je veux encore
évoluer mais jusqu'à présent je n'ai pas
je ne suis pas pour l'imprescribilité
euh parce que alors j'entends bien ça
n'est pas une hiérarchie mais malgré
tout c'est un peu comme ça qu'on l'
qu'on traite les choses au niveau des
peines avec une hiérarchie et le crime
contre l'humanité est imprescriptible
aujourd'hui et c'est le seul euh pour
autant je pense que ce qu'il faut et et
la plupart des victimes ont besoin
d'être reconnu comme étant victime et
que l'auteur soit reconnu comme étant
auteur euh et que ça n'est pas forcément
lié à une judiciarisation une peine et
donc je crois qu'il y a tout un autre
travail à faire éventuellement parallèle
parce que ce que disait anque billon sur
le fait que certains
ou certaines attend la prescription pour
pouvoir aller parler c'est pour pouvoir
être reconnu et sans forcément que ça
ait une réelle conséquence parce
qu'effectivement ils sont encore dans le
système mais sans cela il n'y serait pas
allé donc je pense que c'est c'est
forcément un peu plus complexe par
contre je voulais continuer sur le fait
que il y a effectivement l'amnésie
traumatique et évidemment il faut en
tenir compte il y a le fait que une une
chose peut être prescrite mais si on
retrouve une victime qui est plus
récente que ça puisse faire de nouveau
on puisse faire appel à la victime
ancienne il y a énormément d'aménagement
encore possible avant même d'aller vers
l'imprescriptibilité pour l'instant je
suis pour ça mais peut-être que
j'évolurai n verrons alors il nous reste
plus que 5 minutes le le temps affiler
beaucoup trop vite dans ce débat mais je
voudrais quand même qu'on consacre ces 5
dernières minutes à l'avenir de la
civise Milie zapalski 23 janvier 2021
c'est le jour où Emmanuel Macron a a
annoncé la création de la la la
commission mandat qui devait durer 3 ans
elle devrait poursuivre ses activités
oui elle devrait continuer à exister
avec des missions élargies une nouvelle
feuille de route on parle de pédoc
criminalité en ligne d'accès à la
pornographie d'éducation à la sexualité
des enfants de prostitution des mineurs
en tout cas c'est ce qu' déclaré
Charlotte cobbel secrétaire d'État à
l'enfance dans une interview au Journal
du Dimanche elle l'a confirmé mardi à
l'Assemblée nationale elle a dit que les
détails devraiit être présentés dans les
prochaines semaines il y avait des
inquiétudes oui il y avait un flou qui
régnait à tel point qu'il y a eu une
lettre qui a été faite une lettre
ouverte au président de la République
par les 36 membres de la délégation aux
droits des femmes du Sénat pour demander
son maintien il y a une pétition aussi
qui tourne actuellement pour le maintien
de ses co-présidents dont Édouard Duran
ici présent il ne serait pas conduit en
tout cas c'est ce qu'on entend dans le
cadre de cette nouvelle feuille de route
est-ce que son travail c'est un peu
particulier de parler de vous alors que
vous êtes dans dans la salle n'aurait
pas convaincu et ben on peut se dire que
au contraire si est peut-être un petit
peu trop avec des critiques virulentes
sur le système judiciaire un ton très
engagé peut-être trop engagé pour le
gouvernement Charlotte cobel mardi à
l'Assemblée a dit ce n'est pas le combat
d'un seul homme je ne sais pas si elle
vous parler de vous elle a dit c'est le
combat du gouvernement du Parlement de
tous les adultes de notre pays d'après
les informations du Parisien le
gouvernement chercherait une équipe avec
des experts d'autre nature en gros un
petit peu moins critique sur l'action
publique en matière d'inceste mais
est-ce que des personnalités justement
engagées sont pas indispensables pour
mener ces combats surtout pour s'assurer
que les mesures sont prises au bout du
bout ouais et qu'elles sont à la hauteur
je vous pose la question Édouard durant
vous êtes prêt à continuer avec Nathalie
Mathieu qui est co-présidente de la
civise bien sûr je je le demande oui
c'est un engagement bien sûr que ce
n'est pas le combat d'un homme j'ai très
mal vécu cette cette sortie qui qui qui
est presque insultante ce n'est pas le
combat d'un homme c'est évident et
simplement les les les personnes
engagées ne sont pas jetables non plus
personne n
rableable est-ce que c'est parce que
vous parlez entre guillemets he trop
fort ça me fait penser aussi à Jean-Marc
Sauvet qui présidait la la la sièe la
commission indépendante sur les abus
sexuels dans dans l'église qui a
notamment entre autres finalement pas
été reu par le pape François est-ce que
ce qui parlent trop fort finissent par
déranger vous voyez ce que je veux dire
oui je il y a une forme de symétrie en
effet qui rejoint ce que disait madame
la Présidente Dominique Verrien tout à
l'heure en début he il il y a quelqu'un
qui est rejeté dans l'histoire nous
parlons de ça ou hein dans une culture
du dénis il y en a un qui est rejeté il
y en a un qui paye on lui dit reproche
même son engagement évidemment que c'est
pas le combat d'un homme c'est le combat
d'une
société vous savez on fait des choix
dans la vie moi j'ai j'ai j'ai choisi
que je voulais comme juge des enfants
que les enfants et les victimes de
violence se
disent il me comprend et ce rapport de
750 pages et bien hier encore quand je
je recevais une une femme victime en
audition à la civise elle me disait j'ai
cru lire ma biographie à ch à chaque
page et bien pourquoi pas pourquoi
arrêter ça vous voyez et oui je crois
Jean-Marc sou dit ils ont flingué mon
rapport auprès du pape ou il y a il y a
cette forme de symétrie parce que ouais
ce ce qui dérange ce n'est pas la
couleur de mes cheveux ce n'est pas euh
ma le ton de ma voix c'est ce qui se dit
c'est le contenu et la fin du dénis àou
le mot de la conclusion oui oui donc ça
c'est la la problématique aussi des
lanceurs d'alertes on a on est lanceur
d'alerte à la civise mais il y a il y a
quand même quelque chose qui est
vraiment essentiel et qu'on ne peut pas
étouffer c'est tout toutes ces toutes
ces victimes qui ont témoigné toutes
celles qui croient qui ont qui ont du
coup beaucoup oup d'espoir dans l'action
de de la civise et qu'on ne peut pas
décevoir il faut rappeler que c'est
justement après 80000 tweets sur Twitter
que du coup cette cette cette nouvelle
commission a été mise en place pour dire
qu'on voulait justement que le président
voulait vraiment croire que les victimes
seraient jamais seules et là avec la
civise telle qu'elle est telle qu'elle a
été conçue avec notre engagement à tous
euh et bien justement on entend les
victimes et les victimes ne se sentent
plus seuls et ça faudrait surtout pas
que ça s'arrête il faut qu'on continue à
être leur porte-voie en en 15 secondes
vous souhaitez que les coprésidents
restent en place alors oui je pense que
c'est important et que quand on est
vraiment engagé du côté du gouvernement
on ne peut pas avoir peur d'avoir un
aiguillon à côté qui nous dit
avancer évidemment c'est parfaitement
contradictoire je pour conclure je
rappelle et ça me semble évident de
terminer ce débat avec cette information
le numéro pour l'enfant sans danger le
119 si vous êtes un enfant en danger si
vous êtes un témoin que vous soutionnez
des violences sexuelles fait à un enfant
si vous souhaitez demander conseil le
119 c'est ouvert 24h/ 24 7 jours sur 7
appel gratuit numéro qui n'est pas
visible sur les factures de téléphone
vous pouvez aussi envoyer un message
écrit sur à l'adresse allo
1119.gou.fr la première ministre a
annoncé euh des moyens renforcés pour le
119 on verra bien dans les jours à venir
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat merci euh émidie également Notter
que demain l'écrivain et académicien ERC
orsena sera l'invité d'orian Mancini
dans la matinale de Public Sénat bonne
soirée
[Musique]
merci